so in celebration of fathers i want to
give a shout out to the greatest father
i had and that's my pops gabriel david
who changed my life not because we lived
in a big house not because we had all
the nice cars or travel the world or i
had the nice jays or clothes none of
that stuff but it taught me the right
values of principles of hard work every
day keeping your word every day going
out there doing things that seem
impossible being somebody that's proud
of your heritage your country giving
back all of those things i got from him
i salute you but by the way there's a
lot of great other other great fathers
out there maybe you maybe your father i
salute you you matter so much one of the
reasons why
fathers are so special is because what
you do today we may not see the positive
consequences for a decade two or three
that's a long time but i know how
important you are because my father made
a big impact in my life so i salute you
however
in because of that we have decided to do
a 15 discount on father's day so if you
haven't yet registered for the vault to
spend two and a half days together in
miami click on the link above or below
get registered i'll see you in miami
first week of september take care
everybody bye-bye